Many times, when you have complicated conditions, you want to combine them. For
example, maybe you want to do something if one condition is true, or another
one. In Java, there are three operators that you can use to combine conditions.
They look like this. The two ampersands are an and these two vertical bars are
on or. And the exclamation mark somewhat is a not. You might find it useful to
remember that the not equal operator that you've seen a few units ago also has
the exclamation mark. Let me show you a few examples for using these operators.
And once again, we'll be looking at flags where the visual appearance should
help you. Let's start with this maritime flag for the letter d. Here, I made a
sketch of this flag. When you're in the middle, the pixel should be blue. And
otherwise, it should be yellow. So how do we express when you're in the middle?
When the y-value is greater than this level. And less than this level, that's
where our and comes in, then we're in the middle. This here is 1 5th of the
total height. So, we have two conditions, namely y is at least height over 5,
and the other condition is y is at most height times 4 over 5. Both conditions
have to be fufilled for us to be in the middle, so we use the and operator.
Here it is. Let's just try this out. Here is the condition that you just saw
with the and operator here. And in this case, we return blue. Otherwise, we
return yellow. In this case, I will make a square flag and here it is. So, the
and operator worked out for us. Because we wanted y to be at least here at
most, here. Both conditions had to be true for the blue color. Now, let's look
at another flag. I've sketched up the flag here. And the question is, when
should a pixel be blue. In this case, there are four conditions. The x-value
should be at least width over third. That means it's over here. The x-value
should be at most, width times two thirds. That makes it over here. The y-value
should be the height over 3, and the y-value should be at most the height times
two third. All those four conditions need to be fulfilled for a pixel to be
built. Now, it's your turn. You'll get to write a program that draws this flag
here with a bit of blue on the inside and white on the outside.